when you're in Germany you eat sausage
that's pretty much what they have they
have a lot of sausage here
I had sausage for breakfast you have
sausage for lunch you have sausage for
dinner I went to a bar they put sausage
in a glass and you drink it it's crazy
see that little girl over there
that's a sausage lollipop she's like I'm
gonna go inside find out how it all
happens this is your name sir Marcos
benzoyl you make sausage
vishka no I'm as a mastaba Tomas give a
master yes making sausage was she well I
have a high opinion of yourself deal Oh
permit Falls okay
sweeper metaphors right battle bull
wolves time well but when liebe forced
the worst semester my tongue won't do
the language right I'm worried that use
my tongue around you might snatch it
make it into a sausage this guy oh I
have to tell you that looks awful was in
a horrible accident
you go from Missha all for me show you
can i oh yes
what's inside first you eat Zola danke
so here yeah
and salami salami so no no no great
we're gonna make some sausage I don't
want to go in here with that if I'm
never heard from again
find me avenge me you again in a way I
am the sausage maker my show and the
people laughing are sausages people
laugh that's a sausage that's my sausage
people laughing you make your sausages
which are made of pieces of animal and I
make my sausages which is the smiles
mice misunderstand
yes clear this is the cuff sausage that
I made what I'm doing today not actually
making sausage but making people laugh
that's my sausage did I over explain it
too much too much with me explaining let
me get a little more a little more yes
when I make people laugh your sausage
for me I am my sausage man only I don't
make sausages I make people smile and
laugh so when I make someone laugh the
laughter that they come out of their
face is a sausage when I people laugh
the noise they make is my sausage then
so I that's how I feel my world with my
sausages
you see want me to explain a little more
[Applause]
we make to Jesus a global compost group
of bratwurst and then we make fine a pot
roast
what is that what's in there what's that
I will kiss it now that I've seen that I
have to go don't I know okay okay
sausage goes in there what are you doing
what's happening
you're insane and the TV not going on
for you you can come here and walk when
I'm no longer on TV I can come work for
you yes you'd be a good boss of a fun
buy you a fun boss
yeah what happens if a it said no like
Hans right
I'm bronze guys you got out of line
[Music]
oh I can eat you can eat is very good
it's raw yeah yes why don't you go first
okay ready hey testing over this tube
come on tuck tuck tuck
what [ __ ] yeah feel like I'm jerking off
a robot look this is a big sausage ah
it's a Tripucka german sausage oh very
good
do you think maybe you'd let me run the
shop one day can I ever be the boss of
the shop
you